[Música]
a apresentação fica complicado ter
alguma coisa né
podia ficar podíamos ficar por aqui
depois de um instrumento musical não
iremos ter um malabarismo magia na
hipnose
ok não é disso que eu vou falar que não
vou falar também da minha da minha
experiência profissional pode trazer sim
de visão que o time para o futuro que é
por isso que estamos aqui hoje nem o que
será o futuro como é que vai ser
e para isso se tornar um crime mais
direto e eu decidi trazer uma analogia
com os playmobil ao jovem com um plano
eu não tenho vergonha quem tá ruim no
som a dizer que sim está tudo mais ou
menos da minha geração veículos cotas
têm mais hábitos prêmio nobel mas vocês
vão ver que de fato temos a aprender
algumas coisas continuam a ver
essencialmente com história com a
história da marca
por isso é que criei um pequeno lote
exclusivo para o terek fiz aqui um
upgrade ao logo dos anos começarmos
gostaria que todos vocês tirarem os
telemóveis gols
após arrumar mas queremos usar o que é
que vocês fazem assaltos
quando chego é esse procurar uma ficha
não é por causa da dengue
agora vamos pedir a cada um de vocês que
faça uma self só vocês sei que elas
possam um nada disso é uma coisa simples
mas aí falei você olhar para o meu lado
de uma self já fizeram a self
vamos dar uma informação muito
importante para tirar uma fotografia a
pessoa mais importante do vosso tudo só
vocês é só isto é deus votaram
será que o momento um caminho romântico
de coisa mas faltava a pouco o nosso
primeiro incremento falou sobre isso que
nós somos capazes ou podemos ser capazes
quase tudo
inicialmente nós então como é que será
este futuro e o que eu aprendi ao longo
dos meus dez 12 anos de vida
profissional
aprendi que só conhecemos uma condição
quando eu era miúdo em frança havia
muitas vezes desanimava que era uma vez
o homem era uma vez o corpo humano e num
dos episódios do era uma vez o homem
este senhor este gênio é pergunta
criança pergunta o gênio
qual é a minha condição enquanto ser
humano rogério responde existem três
aspectos indispensáveis à condição
humana não irá escolher sua família
o local antonaccio e trocou o papel a
partir daí o sonho é o limite de sua
realização pessoal pois tem pessoas como
michael jackson consegue mudar a cor
papel mas por norma mantemos o mesmo
corpo até o final da nossa da nossa da
nossa vida não é um estranhamento com o
passar dos anos descobri que vivemos
numa sociedade bastante estranhas que
sofrem que manipular podemos assim dizer
não é o que eu digo não é o que eu sinto
que eu sei que muitas vezes não é o
clube que vivemos hoje em dia numa
sociedade divulga um estudo é volátil
incerto
vejam as relações do trabalho não é só o
simples é que admiram isto é complexa
desenvolvendo e desempenhamos vários
papéis ao longo da nossa vida às vezes
entra agora em que tem amigos e
ambiguidade das nossas opções enquanto
ser humano é muito estranho que muitas
vezes nós temos cada vez mais acesso à
informação mas cada vez mais difícil
escolher escolher para onde é que eu em
passar um fim de semana por onde é que
nós vamos temos tanta informação com os
problemas nessa procura constante e
desenvolver um sentimento de medo de
escolher e esse medo de escolher muitas
vezes condiciona também o nosso o nosso
futuro
veja um exemplo de como a nossa chegada
é complexa e muitas vezes quiser à
frente
temos dois cães um anda e fala o outro
o que é isto eu lembro de ser criança e
pressionar constantemente eo pior é com
evando do outro
só que com o passar dos anos vamos
conseguindo perceber e acima de tudo o
que é uma conclusão já por falarmos
disso no intervalo
esta grande que o time entrou em cima
e competência as universidades escolas
fóruns moldamos muitas vezes na lógica
da aquisição da informação e os melhores
do que os que conseguirem vão
transformar essa informação em
conhecimento
mas será que é isso que o mercado
trabalhista nós conhecimento apenas eu
acredito que muito mais do conhecimento
que é importante enxergamos a nossa
caixa antes de ser ver caixa
porque muita gente fala que é preciso
sair da caixa só que não tinha nada a
perder ao mundo possível muitas caixas
só que não vou devolver nava e o
conhecimento só faz sentido quando a
mudança do comportamento e essa mudança
no comportamento exige o desenvolvimento
uma competência
por isso o conhecimento é importante nos
preocupamos também com as nossas
competências e quando nós falamos tudo
podemos falar do poetry dixon que é uma
das grandes referências nas tendências e
no futuro o que nos deixa este indicador
sobre aquilo que é o futuro então vai
ser rápido vai ser urbano vai ser igual
universal radical é e os prémios mas que
seja também ético né
então onde eu quero chegar alguns de
vocês já pensaram de quem estava aqui há
três ou quatro anos
é aquela pergunta difícil mãe quando a
medida quando os incêndios têm filhos
mulheres duas cabeças ou não não é
especialista josé onde eu quero chegar
por isso eu desempenhei desenvolver aqui
uma pequena tarefa pra você escolha
senão votar no final para vocês fazerem
uma reflexão em casa que é onde eu estou
neste momento e onde quer chegar daqui a
três quatro ou 51 e vocês vão colocar as
ações as atividades chaves pois vão
permitir alcançar os nossos objetivos
um trabalho pessoal reflexão que vale
pra todos nós mesmo quando estamos
envolvidos no nosso trabalho na nossa em
nossa vida
então onde eu quero chegar e como é que
eu posso a chegar vamos pensar o que
está acontecendo na será quem é que nós
somos quais são os comportamentos de
massa que estão a acontecer jogos vocês
repararam que querem vez mais marcas com
o exame como h&m desenvolve linhas de
vestuário que nem são para homens e uma
mulher
o novo gênero velho e fico para ficar
esta preocupação de equilibrar uns
evitarmos rua júlio rosa nos brinquedos
e wolmar com estados unidos já não têm
peso na cor rosa nessas são brinquedos
utiliza cores neutras né
outro comportamento bastante
interessante que nós vemos cada vez mais
em cidade por sinalizarem com a criação
de valor envolver o consumidor na
criação de conteúdos educativos wii que
há é um estudante exemplo isso
permite-nos customizar os nossos
equipamentos
yannick também faz com uma simples
sapatilhas é conectividade que vocês
nasceram numa geração maior parte ou
seja já estão envolvidos entre na
atividade física dizer com voz e sanfona
o vosso sul no terceiro quarto graças a
vocês devem ter dois ou três quando eu
estava no local o tablet e esta cidade
está com conectados entre nós mas também
com os equipamentos irá continuar o que
nós nos preocupamos hoje em dia
trabalhamos muito sem dúvida alguma eo
equilíbrio entre profissão e que nós
somos enquanto pessoa tem sido uma
preocupação bastante grande como é sair
existe essa preocupação como é que nós
podemos fazer como é que nós podemos
ajudar os outros tentem vender e tentei
arranjar tempo para os outros ganhar
tempo será uma das grandes janelas de
oportunidades para o futuro processos
automação do processo é aplicações web
site plataformas sem dúvida alguma será
o futuro vender um tempo as pessoas
enriqueçam pensei nisso enquanto negócio
depois por fim quando grande tendência
temos a experiência nos pagam 3 mil e 4
mil dólares para ir para o fundo do
canal para aproveitarem o silêncio só e
apenas em um hotel
a experiência vale muito mais do
contributo do produto
se fosse assim vocês não consumiram coca
cola quem consome coca cola aqui sem
vergonha estivessem se lessem todos
disse que ele permanece na lata de
coca-cola os atributos do produto não
tocariam em qualquer com vocês não se
anuncia relacionar com experiência que a
coca cola promove por isso é importante
hoje pode ser um dia diferente pra vocês
um marco da reflexão como eu já tinha
alguns aqui até inclusive néné e
gostaria de deixar esta frase para vocês
pensarem aqui fazer uma ponta para o
conhece que só vamos conseguir o melhor
no futuro fazendo o melhor
neste preciso momento porque ainda vou
falar nos diz presente passado e futuro
pelos vistos já existiram todos ao mesmo
tempo
do ponto de vista físico então já
estamos em prejuízo
vamos correr atrás do nosso futuro
rapidamente então que competências é que
nós todos os planos para o futuro
umas delas temos a capacidade das
funções problemas complexos
isto é irmos mais além daquilo que é a
visão redutora do ok temos um problema
vou resolver é ver mais além desse
problema é a capacidade que nós vamos
ter de ver o problema é trás do pano
depois teremos ter uma capacidade de
pensamento crítico não é aceitar tudo
com 10 da mesma forma é ter uma
capacidade de reflexão sobre aquilo que
josé foi possível com o jec chega até as
mãos porque foi assim por exemplo alegre
ea economia entrou em constante desafio
não é especialmente crítica eu tenho um
para com o outro faz com que os cris são
também nos negócios criatividade será
sem dúvida alguma um dos fatores de
diferenciação que a inteligência
artificial ainda não conseguem terminar
o nível de tal comando do som é
capacidade de compressão ainda são
fatores humanos emocionais que sejam
criativos e às vezes a criatividade não
passa por fazer um só tempo foi a fim de
ali irmos ao teatro aprendemos a tocar
um instrumento junto com a nova eu não
toco nada no campeonato mas a gente pega
uma guitarra teve que sair não é
importante
não temos medo e o primeiro orador falar
sobre isso entramos em campo não são
desconhecidos
não sei se vocês alguns de vocês leram
um livro que está no ano passado foi o o
livro mais vendido dos mais vendidos no
mundo que é sutil arte de espanã de
facto um palavrão aqui na escola
superior de educação e é esse facto é
este livro é fantástico porque o que nos
mostra e faz darmos uma reflexão sobre
aquilo que é funcional enquanto estava o
anel e como é que nós podemos alcançar
isso é sem dúvida
encarando os momentos menos positivos
negativos e superá los através do nosso
esforço e dedicação e inteligência
emocional a capacidade de entender e
aceitar parque relacionaram com as
emoções dos outros também será uma
competência do futuro como tem sido essa
que as máquinas não têm ainda não é a
flexibilidade cognitiva há pouco falou
curiosidade será fundamental termos de
curiosidade a curiosidade não é só eco
da manhã os jornais e também tocar em
coisas que nós não estamos habituados a
tocar e tentar relacionar domínios do
saber
eu posso não ser designer mas há coisas
do design podem ser o centro da nossa
música nosso técnico de som mas há
coisas que eu possa aprender com isso e
teremos que ter essa capacidade de nos
relacionar com outro domínio
tem uma frase que gosto bastante e isso
pode ser o início de uma mudança pra
vocês que é melhor do que está feito
está feito
quando assumimos não era o objetivo
muitas vezes dizem que ao menos por
cento no preço e na maior parte das
vezes suas forças às tribos no solário
éramos todos ricos
o flamengo não tem muitas vezes o
esforço não chega né pq meu objetivo
convertido então é perfeição não existe
mas tentei trabalhar pra ela não estou a
ver com isso para vocês serem de uso né
mas trabalhem pela perfeição
agora quando estiver feito sim mas
também realizados e não frustrados
muitas vezes também acontece isso que
quando nós não conseguimos fazer como
pensamos sentimos frustrados eo grande
muito tempo sentindo assim e quem me
conhece sabe que eu gosto das coisas
biazi sem muitas oscilações de querer
que as coisas aconteçam assim só que ele
também criava em nós e cria ansiedade
stress e não estar por isso vai ter um
trabalho feito é melhor do prefeito o
que os playmobil alguns trazem o que nós
podemos aprender com os leilões já vem
com pouca gente brigou plena vila não
ser os velhos nem do seu onde eu também
estou incluído não é ruim que era
absurdo - vai parece dado o seu que
reúnem os planos dão nos uma lição de em
vários pontos
o primeiro brincar é fundamental não é
porque estamos na escola não é porque
estamos no ambiente corporativo que não
devemos brincar quando nós brincamos
estimulamos os nossos sentidos
trabalhamos empatia trabalhamos a
criatividade trabalhamos a partilha e
quando nós apresentamos um trabalho
quando nós vimos um tev
quando nós desenvolvemos uma formação
contínua de teatros brincar continua a
ser um momento saudável pela nossa
aprendizagem pois não tenham medo de
brincar em segundo seja o novo a ele
isso você já venceram nesta área não é
um plano b e eu percebi rapidamente que
crianças são diferentes as peças vão se
perdendo então criamos umas bolinhas uma
linha dessas completou do lado que criam
cenários não podem estar aqui como podem
estar allen e vocês também devem ser
assim
dominei vários canais de comunicação do
mineiro várias plataformas para se
conseguir relacionar em vários momentos
em vários países e não só e apenas no
local no nosso tempo depois um aspecto
interessante
sorrir alguém gosta de subir
quem gosta de ver um sorriso bonito a
prova é que você se exigem mais dos
outros vocês dão é curioso né
este facto o sorriso do espanhol é marca
disponível desde o primeiro traz design
1971 e mantém o mesmo trás dos riscos
porém como todos os fatos 31 muitos não
eram de sítio e os riscos de não ser o
mesmo
esta importância do nosso risco resulta
da nossa capacidade de assumir os
estados emocionais dos outros e olhe
passando de sandro a sorrir com mais
facilitada também vou sorrir por sentir
essa positividade
se vocês querem um trabalho de mototáxi
objetivo é óbvio que vocês também vão
sentir isso
então nós portugueses somos muito bons
nisso algo está mal toda a gente fica
mal dos dez minutos é bastante direta no
domingo vai o oficina e isso vai ser o
início do fim mas também funciona o
resto porque não é só no negativo algo
muito importante que o plano b conseguiu
ao longo de todos os anos foi a sua
capacidade de adaptação à quadra nesta
terça feira de cor rosa está ali do lado
esquerdo
é um plano b em 1974 rock e temos ali um
playmobil 2004 logo porém as diferenças
entre a senhora
curiosamente programa barriga e as
partes saia e tem umas calças em uma
camisa executaram sou um dos tempos é
maior adaptação que é problema meu teve
ao longo de sua história
foi nos anos 70 porque 1973 tivemos a
grande crise do petróleo que tiveram uma
descida tão simples como reduzir os
custos com os brinquedos e sabem como é
que os fizeram querida entre os media
encolheram os bonecos
os black tinham 20 30 e 40 centímetros e
os ensinasse não temos que otimizar
então vamos otimizar o nosso playmobil
como sete peças no máximo por um momento
e nós fazer 7.5 de altura no máximo cabo
não gosto uma criança
conseguimos reduzir os custos e os
conseguiram se adaptar ao mercado o
preço do metal estava quero marcar o
plástico também então adaptar
rapidamente ao local e nós temos que ter
essa capacidade de adaptação
como é que nós conseguimos fazer e renda
não há ninguém tão inteligente que seja
capaz de aprender com os erros dos
outros
por isso comenta os nossos erros quanto
mais cedo começar melhor meia hora e
mais rapidamente nós vamos adaptar
a seguir o erro é de facto fundamental é
provável também já errou e continua a
encarar como todos nós em qualquer
momento da nossa vida
devemos aprender como erro josé é
apresentar na frente jorge aprendizagem
pelo erro continua a ser das melhores
formas que nós podemos ter para aprender
muitas vezes não temos margem para o
erro
o dizem que não temos margem para o erro
por isso meu desafio é você ser em plena
bill e dos bravos clinton os patos nós
somos um pote 1 bilhão é coisa de piadas
foram os bravos em frente e aqui se
playmobille dos bravos metros por aqui
merece a nossa capacidade de criar
testar e raro e adaptar foi ontem feito
isso ao longo de sua história e vocês
também devem fazer o vosso percurso vai
ser marcado essencialmente por um
percurso até aos 35 anos
vocês não vão ter formas em temporada
assenta esta licenciatura em gestão
fazer aqui neste momento é o início é o
início eu acho quer dizer que o início
do início o ponto zero
muitas mais licenciaturas vocês vão ter
pela vida ou terão que ter que se
adaptar é que o que esperado pelo
mercado trabalho daqui cinco anos na
austrália então o curso de comunicação
social publicidade vai ser uma etapa mas
apenas uma pequena etapa
essa reciclagem de conhecimentos será
fundamental a gente pensava para vocês
deixamos aqui claro na mensagem queremos
parece que nem tudo é negativo né e
deixar aqui uma reflexão e também
aprendi ao longo do nosso curso
profissional
existe muito mais força do que te lento
na maior parte das nossas conquistas
muitas vezes as pessoas dizem esforço
brilhantes se tiveres um indescritível
idade o vadão que espetacular
tu vai ser o melhor eu cresci a ouvir
isso relativamente à licenciatura tirar
uma licenciatura vai ser alguém
nós não somos policiais ninguém somos o
único a nossa família nossos amigos
somos únicos especiais só o tempo ea
nossa capacidade de desenvolver
conhecimento à competência o dirá
por isso não não continua a alimentar
essa essa falácia de que somos todos
especiais porque nós somos somos o único
para um terminal hall pessoas e para vos
mostrar de uma forma simples que existe
mais força do que talento
nas nossas conquistas boxeadores que se
levantem não é pra ir embora
ok faz e não com alguma velocidade em 45
segundos e ouvi dizer como é que o caio
é porque nem fazer uma coisa muito
simples
ok construir que coloca os braços à
frente porque basicamente o que eu vou
fazer
tentem ter um mínimo de segurança com a
malta está ao nosso lado e entrar em
choque não podem colocar os dois braços
à frente
assim fechem os olhos durante cinco
segundos
cuidado com as carteiras em 1930 por
nota que vai passar atrás vocês não é
agora podem abrir outra vez à saúde
tanto brincar
agora vamos usar o momento pato bravo né
brinca
agora vamos colocar você mão esquerda no
ombro direito
assim e agora vamos atrás assim como
estará o ponto só uma vez num carlos
anjos está agora vai voltar a fazer o
mesmo
os olhos durante cinco segundos na ásia
podem braço geralmente mão esquerda no
ombro direito e agora vocês vão cuidar
pra trás tentando chegar o mais longe
possível
ok vão fixar esse ponto é curioso que a
malta ficou muito mais mães não é saber
por que uma coisa tão simples deve ter
um propósito e um foco e muitas vezes o
que nos falta para nós conseguirmos
alcançar os objetivos
um propósito e um foco lembrem sempre
que as vossas jet virados nossas ações
os projetos as nossas presenças serão a
vossa história por consequente serão a
vossa imagem de marca pelo bem e pelo
mal
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
[Risadas]